okay so next session is about five is
learning the first speaker is Mark bang
who tell us about boosting in noise :
tell me he's a fellow here okay thank
you for the introduction ory thank
everybody for coming
I'll be talking today about some work
done in collaboration with Marko karma
see know and just Sorrell from UC San
Diego which actually started sort of at
the tail end of last semester simon
program on lower bounds and complexity
theory and maybe we'll see a connection
between the topic of this talk boosting
and complexity theory a bit later in the
talk so I'm gonna start out with a
disclaimer oh boy my slides
I'm missing a bunch of content
there we go so I'll just talk with a
disclaimer which is that this is a work
in progress so I'm going to try to
restrict myself to telling you things
that I think are true but as we all know
like differential privacy can be a bit
subtle so if anybody during the talk
identify something that they see is like
a serious blender or something please
like feel free to call me out on it all
right
so the topic of this talk is going to be
about boosting which should be a
familiar topic too many people anybody's
the setup is as follows we have some
data domain X and we have some unknown
boolean function over this data domain
we'll call f we have some unknown
distribution D over X so a strong
learning algorithm is going to be given
a sequence of labeled examples which are
iid draws from this distribution D
together with the label determined by
this boolean function f and the goal of
the strong learner is to produce a
hypothesis which is itself a boolean
function over the domain X and which
hopefully agrees with the target
function f and you know generalizes to
the underlying distribution in the sense
that with high probability over a fresh
sample from the underlying distribution
it agrees with a target function f ok so
boosting is a technique which relates
strong learning to a different notion
called weak learning which is like
essentially the same thing it's the same
set up where you have iid draw from a
distribution and your goal is to produce
hypothesis but this time the accuracy
guarantee on the hypothesis is a lot
weaker so instead of agreeing with the
target function f with high probability
very close to 1 over fresh examples you
only need to agree with it with slightly
better probability than just random
guessing so like 1/2 plus C for some
small parameter C think of it as like
inverse polynomial or something okay so
again boosting is a technique for
relating these two notions
and particular it's a technique for
converting these weak learners which do
slightly better than random guessing
into strong learners alright so give you
a brief overview of how a number of
boosting algorithms and a literature
work so this is sort of the template
that a lot of important algorithms in
particular the famous adaboost algorithm
of friendship uri operates so again the
input to what will eventually be a
strong learner is a labelled sample s
and it's given access or like Oracle
access it can't go to a weak learner
which has some advantage C over random
guessing so the strong learner is going
to operate by repeatedly calling the
weak learner on the sample s but with
different weights where the weights on
the sample s are going to be chosen
adaptively depending on the performance
of the weak learner in previous
iterations so this boosted algorithm is
going to start by initializing the
uniform distribution over samples it's
going to feed the sample waited by the
uniform distribution so basically just
the sample itself the weak learner
produced a hypothesis use the hypothesis
to sort of focus attention on the parts
of the sample s where the first
hypothesis h1 was doing badly and then
feed this new distribution over samples
into the weak learner again produce a
hypothesis and so on and so forth
producing this long sequence each one
through HT of hypotheses ok so the way
that these intermediate distributions
over the sample are determined is
according to this important
multiplicative weights update rule which
again is going to place mass
proportional to like exponential in like
sort of cumulatively how badly the
previous sequence of hypotheses was
doing on a sample all right and at the
end of the day once you've done T equals
roughly log 1 over alpha over C squared
iterations you can just output sort of
like the majority vote
of the hypothesis that you fed into this
okay and then this was going to produce
a strong learner which has error most
alpha with respect to the original
sample s okay any questions all right so
let's see a nice example of boosting an
action so I'm going to give the example
of learning a large margin half space
which is very closely related to the
notion of learning functions with little
mark and complexity that Vitali
introduced before the break and this
particular way of using boosting to
learn a large margin half space is
through to Sir video from 20 years ago
like almost all of my research projects
they begin this by looking at some paper
Rocco wrote 20 years ago and so in this
problem we're given a data domain X
which is just the unit l2 ball and RD
for some D the target function is going
to be a half space over this domain so
it's the sine of the inner product of
some unit vector W with the example X
we're going to make the following large
margin assumption on the pair F comma D
or D is the distribution over examples
where we enforce the condition that for
every point X and the support of the
distribution D the inner product between
W and X is at least gamma so that means
you know every point in the distribution
is going to be at least distance gamma
away from the separating hyperplane okay
so for video constructed a very nice
simple clean weak learner for half space
which works as follows
so the input to the weak learner is
going to be now a pair consisting of
label these labeled sample s together
with weights for how much attention the
weak learner should be placing to it on
of the samples okay and what the weak
learner is going to do is it's going to
produce a you know the thing that goes
into the sine function when defining a
half space so the inner product between
a unit vector and domain item X where
this unit vector W is obtained by taking
a weighted average of the label times
the example for each point in the sample
okay where the weights are chosen
according to the way it's passed into
the week later so one thing to note
about this is that it doesn't quite
follow the syntax of week learning that
I introduced them the first slide don't
worry about it like these frameworks are
like fairly adaptable and finding a weak
learner in terms of a real valued
predictor is like useful for analysis so
we'll just do it this way okay so one
way to think about what this weak
learner is doing is its looking at the
points in the labeled sample and for all
of the points labeled - its reflecting
them to be you know the negative of that
point and then assigning them the
positive label and then it just computes
sort of like the center of attention of
this like cloud of positive points
admission ideally have some correlation
with the underlying vector W that you're
trying to predict all right okay so
here's what Rocco showed about this weak
learner for half space so if the labeled
sample s indeed comes from a half space
that has margin gamma then this real
valued hypothesis that you're produces
is going to have advantage at least like
gamma over 2 or gammas together market
and this is going to hold with respect
to the sample all right so how do you
prove such a thing it's extremely simple
the probably the hardest part of the
proof is defining what it means to have
good advantage for a
a real-valued learner so it's going to
be the advantage so like your advantage
over random guessing is going to be
given by this expression so where does
this come from
well if H is just you know doing no
better than random guessing then it's
then you can take H to be 0 on all
points so what you get here is 1/2 minus
1/2 which is advantage 0 if H is
perfectly predicting Y so H agrees let's
lie on every sample then these gaps are
all 0 and you have advantage 1/2 and
then this is just the natural like
linear interpolation for real valued H
ok so to prove this advantage found you
do some algebra you can compute the
advantages half of the l2 norm of the
thing that goes into W before you
normalize it meanwhile you can get a
lower bound on this expression using the
margin condition and again you do some
algebra these cookie short somewhere use
the fact that W has l2 norm 1 compared
these expressions and then you get
advantage over to us ok so pretty simple
fits on it with half a slide alright so
let's see what you can do by feeding
this weak learner into city at a boost
algorithm so again we know that this
weak learner has advantage at least game
over to this theorem of friendship Yuri
shows that if you plug this into the
adaboost algorithm then after about log
1 over alpha over gamma squared rounds
you're going to be able to guarantee
that the hypothesis was error alpha with
respect to the sample s all right so
getting good error with respect to the
sample is nice but ideally we'd like to
have the hypothesis we generate
generalize to the underlying
distribution so this requires a little
bit more work and sir video was able to
show that if the hypothesis is that the
hypothesis actually has error alpha with
respect to the underlying distribution
as long as the number of samples is at
least about 1 over L gamma squared ok
and this basically matches what you can
get for
this problem of learning a large
American house space using like the
perceptron algorithm and the proof of
this result of this generalization
result goes by way of a more detailed
analysis of the adaboost algorithm which
shows that the thing in the sign here
the thing so H itself defines a half
space this improved analysis of adaboost
shows that this half space itself has
large margin with respect to the sample
and then one can use this you know
beautiful and deep theory about
generalization from papyrus with good
margin to show that once you have the
sample complexity
Rocko's theorem here is with respect to
like a specific algorithm right it is
not a general statement it's respect to
with respect to the adaboost algorithm
in particular that's correct
the other was produced large margin over
the ages like you so you have new
features which are division then I have
large margin in the l1 infinity margin
so hey this ages already is up is
enlarging this one gives it there will
be picture one whatever other distinct
is it
they kept repeating over there yes this
is uh but the hypotheses that you
generate are they like real-valued inner
product things so when you sum them up
you again get these ages so it's what
goes under there we've done the other
boosters it's the video weak learner yes
so it's a combination of an analysis of
adaboost with sir videos weak learner
and this exploits I think what you're
saying which is that the underlying
hypotheses are these real valued thanks
but I think there there are analogous
results for a DAB boosts that predated
this particular result which show
generalization using margin balance okay
all right so what are we doing this work
well we're interested in you know doing
learning with differential privacy and
in particular what we'd like to be able
to do is design boosting algorithms that
preserve differential privacy and the
fact and then the sense that they can
take as inputs a differential a private
weak learner and then produce a
differential a private strong learner so
this exact problem was considered by
Salil guy and Cynthia and this was
probably like the third most important
result from that amazing paper and what
we do in this work as we revisit this
private boosting algorithm that they
provided and give a few tweaks to it
simplify and generalize it as an
application of this boosting framework
we give a algorithm for privately
learning large warehouse spaces and this
recover is basically similar basically
the same sample complexity guarantees is
this recent paper of Wayne Ullman and
there can be new
and finally at the end of the talk I'll
have a few musings about the
relationship between differential
privacy and generalization and talk
about how differential privacy you know
automatically guarantees generalization
in spite of you know not necessarily
being able to produce these margin
balance and this leverage is this really
nice connection between differential
privacy and generalization for adaptive
data analysis so again the focus of this
talk is going to be on differentially
private learning so this is the this is
going to use the framework introduced by
cleaners ten years ago and again this
framework should be pretty familiar but
so I'll go through it anyway so guesses
in the ordinary strong learning setting
we're given an unknown function unknown
distribution iid samples from this and a
learner is supposed to produce
hypothesis that generalizes to the
underlying distribution so this paper of
cleaners augmented this model with a
privacy condition which says in the
worst case over input samples so input
samples that could be just like
arbitrary labeled examples not
necessarily come from a distribution or
anything the output of this learner
should be differentially private with
respect to the sample s meaning that if
I take this guy Stephen in the data set
and replace him with somebody who's
cooler in every respect the distribution
of hypotheses output by the learner L
should be statistically close privacy so
formally we can define a private PAC
learning for your favorite notion of
differential privacy meaning look for
all sets will for all pairs of
neighboring samples s and s Prime you
get the epsilon epsilon Delta
differential privacy condition or
concentrate a differential privacy
we'll also need a notion of private week
learning and I'll be a little bit more
precise about the notion of private week
learning that we'll need so again our
week learners are going to not
necessarily output boolean hypotheses
but they're going to output hypotheses
that could be real valued and giving you
something between minus 1 and 1 and our
goal is design to design private week
learners which give you advantage at
least see for some parameter C and sort
of this more general notion of inputs
for weak learners and necessitates a
little bit more an S in how one defines
differential privacy so like the input a
weak learner is now a sample together
with a sequence of weights for each of
the examples so one possible way to do
this is to say that you have for some
parameter Sigma if you have two weighted
samples so say s weighted by some
distribution P and s prime weighted by
some distribution P prime if you compute
the histograms of those two samples
where the weights of the histograms are
determined by the distributions and
those through histograms are closed and
statistical distance close by at most
Sigma ok and then the notion of
differential privacy is that's the
output of the learner when right now
these two things are statistically close
again you can define this for epsilon
Delta R CVP or whatever
notice that this definition collapses to
the usual definition of differential
privacy if you take Sigma to be 1 over N
and you take P to be the uniform
distribution all the time all right
all right so the main question is
whether differentially private weak
learners can be boosted to
differentially private strong learners
again we'll try to work up to this
result of door cross/blue and begun and
tell you about our modification to it so
the first attempt that you might try to
make in designing a differential a
private booster suggests use adaboost
but there's a problem with this so if
you look at this multiplicative weights
update method it's going to be you know
in every round piling on mass
proportional to exponential in whatever
your margin of your last hypothesis was
so if you're really unlucky and you're
in a situation where every weak learner
is doing a terrible job on one
particular example x1 for instance then
your joys going to be like piling on
exponentially more mass on that example
throughout the course of this learning
algorithm and this is bad for privacy
because at the end of the day you're
going to end up with a distribution that
places like a ton of mass on one point
so if you know you change that one point
than the input sample then you're going
to dramatically change what's being fed
in the weak learner and you might fail
to guarantee differential privacy so
aggressive weighting is bad for privacy
so sort of the key idea for getting
around the situation is to restrict the
distributions that the booster is going
to produce over the course of its
execution
so in particular be interested in this
notion of smooth boosting which was
exactly this notion of capping how much
mass the the booster can place on any
one example so formally for some
parameter Sigma suggestively named a
boosting algorithm is Sigma smooth if
the mass of the places on any point I is
at most Sigma for any I on
okay so for the complexity theorist in
the audience this is just another way of
saying that the distribution P always
hasn't been entropy at least loved one
over Sigma okay so this notion of smooth
boosting has been considered in a number
of contexts both in learning theory and
outside learning theory so the best of
my knowledge the first use of smooth
boosting came in this completely
different context of hardness
amplification and complexity theory so
this goes back to an plug we got those
hard core lemma from 1995 where you
showed that if you have some boolean
function which is sort of like mildly
hard to compute on average by circuits
of a given size s then it's actually
very hard to compute by circuits of
slightly smaller size so in particular
you can find a relatively large hard
core of boolean inputs for which
circuits of slightly smaller size can't
do much better than random guessing on
that small set of inputs and the
connection to smooth boosting is that
sort of the bigness of this hard core
set of inputs corresponds to the
smoothness of a boosting algorithm which
implicitly used to do this amplification
and this connection between hardness
amplification and boosting was made
explicit in this beautiful work of type
in the video within learning theory
itself smoo boosting has been used to
design noise tolerant learning
algorithms so sort of using similar
intuition for why smooth boosting is
useful for differential privacy it's
also useful for noise hollering boosting
because intuitively you don't want your
boosting algorithm to pile like
arbitrarily large amounts of mass on
examples that might have been like noisy
you know I miss classified or like not
actually have anything to do with the
distribution that you're trying to learn
over it's also been used to design
boosters for agnostic learning and to
design algorithms in this extended
statistical queries model where
ask us Q queries but they're allowed to
be defined with respect to a
distribution of your choosing rather
than necessarily the target distribution
okay
so give a quick overview of some of the
smooth boosting algorithms available in
the literature so to do this I want to
introduce like a little bit of notation
the first piece of notation is this
notion of a measure and if you think of
a measure as a function whose only
purpose in life is to be normalized into
a distribution so it's going to be a
function from n to 0 one just a
normalized distribution you turn it into
a distribution by box so we're going to
define the total margin at a point I
based on some sequence of hypotheses
that you've produced to be the sum of
the individual margins on those points
and a number of these algorithms will
use a termination criterion which says
like once your measure stops being big
so if it becomes small 1 over Sigma then
you'd better stop and so they're going
to use the invariant that this measure
is at least 1 over Sigma for their
execution ok so just put what we know
into this notation the non-smooth
adaboost algorithm computes its measure
by just taking exponential of the total
margin and what these smooth boosting
algorithms for instance this algorithm
in plug we also do is they restrict
these measures to be stuck between 0 and
1 and also use this invariant defined by
the termination criterion that the total
asses at least 1 over Sigma so because
everything is stuck between 0 and 1 once
you normalize by the measure by the size
of the measure you get something where
all of the points are have Massimo Sigma
ok and then your video gave a different
smooth boosting algorithm which uses
this different definition
so another thing you can do beyond these
sort of like explicit schemes is what I
think of as sort of cheating you can use
this framework of Bregman predictions
where you know you you take this measure
M do the typical like eat a boost kind
of update to it and then just like
projected into the space of smooth
distributions
technique lessons
all right so now we're ready to move on
to the boosting for people algorithm
which uses these ideas of smooth
boosting in order to produce a
differential a private booster so this
again goes comes from the workouts bar
cross limit but on they showed that if
you start with say an epsilon Sigma DP
weak learner where we're going to take
Sigma to be 1 over alpha n so sort of
the intuition for why we want to take
Sigma to be 1 over alpha n is as follows
kind of like the worst thing for the
strong learner that you get at the end
of the day is going to be a distribution
which is uniform over a set of like
alpha and examples in the sample which
corresponds to like a Sigma being 1 over
alpha n smooth distribution so we'll
kind of like work with this fixing of
the parameterization throughout the talk
ok so what they do is is the following
you for t running between 1 and capital
t being like log 1 over alpha over C
squared
you run the weak learner on the sample
weighted by your distribution can do
like a private check to see if you've
done a good job so far and then you have
to do a reading of the distribution of
examples so what they do to do their
reading is they compute this
differentially private noisy cap which
you should think of as like the size of
the measure they're using and they use
this noisy cap together with something
that basically amounts to a brakeman
projection in order to guarantee
smoothness of the distribution that they
so I guess one thing I want to point out
about this is that they do the
multiplicative weights update here with
respect to the normalized distribution
tt that they've that they're trying to
create and then Bregman projected us
down into the space of smooth
distributions
so I questioned you with what's the
purpose of step two here right between
chicken gear you don't really have to do
that it just allows you to do or like
early termination always
alright okay so what we do in this work
is you give a slight simplification of
this that works in a slightly different
setting where the weak learner is
allowed to have real outputs and
guaranteed to give real advantage see
okay it's like pretty similar you know
you run the week learn around the sample
weighted by the current distribution do
some hypothesis and then do some waiting
and then the simplicity we can just not
do any early termination anything this
output the sine of the sum of the
underlying hypotheses I kind of like the
P salient difference I want to point out
about our algorithm is that we do the
multiplicative weights update on the
unnormalized measure MT which I think
saves you from having to do anything
with this noisy cap and stuff and then
we Bregman project this unnormalized
measure onto the space of this gives you
a slight simplification okay so a little
bit more about this lazy normalization I
don't know it's kind of like this one
cool trick that makes machine learning
people hate you maybe but it just uses
the fact that multiplicative weights and
boosting converge even when you apply
updates to this like unpredicted
unnormalized measure and then only like
normalize it when you feed it into the
weak learner money - and this property
has been exploited in several works I
sue Roth Roth garden and Ullman in other
contexts where you want to privately
solve like two-player games and other
applications
we have like useless trick for yet
another thing that multiplicative way it
solves which is boosting sort of the
underlying limit you don't have to read
this that drives the privacy analyses of
these things that if you have like two
unnormalized unprotected measures which
disagree and only one coordinate as long
as those measures are not too big then
when you project them onto the space of
smooth distributions you get
distributions that are close in
statistical distance which is what you
need for privacy so here's the theorem
that we think we can prove so if you
start with a weak learner which is let's
say CD P so that we get advanced
composition epsilon squared over 2 comma
Sigma CD P for Sigma being 1 over alpha
and then you get a boosted learner which
guarantees a CDP criterion you want so
epsilon squared is add up it's going to
have air alpha with respect to the
sample and all of the intermediate
distributions that it generates are
going to be Sigma smooth
that's right it's just counting the
number of iterations and CDP lets you
add up the epsilon Squared's
okay so the analysis of this goes by way
of analyzing approximate equilibrium
computation so you know you think of
pure rose strategies for the row player
as corresponding examples in the domain
pure column strategies are going to
correspond to weak hypotheses that the
weak learner can produce and you want to
show that these smooth boosting
corresponds to like repeatedly playing
this game and converging to an
equilibrium which corresponds to a
strongly accurate hypothesis together
with a small like alpha and size set of
bad examples in which that hypothesis
does poorly so this is like a fairly
standard type of analysis if you want
more details ask Erin about me so
moreover doing the analysis this way
guarantees that you know if you have
real valued weak learners H with good
margin then like the boosted learner
that you get has a good margin on almost
all inputs and it seems to be pretty
flexible to substituting and different
update rules for instance in processors
yes ok so that's the general framework I
want to spend a few minutes telling you
about our application to privately
learning large margin half-spaces
again so so here's the problem your data
domain is a unit ball and Rd you want to
learn a half space with margin at least
gamma your target error rate for the
classifier you produces alpha and you
want to guarantee epsilon differential
privacy or actually what we get is
epsilon squared over Q CVP
okay so there have been a number of
algorithms that consider this problem
probably the first goes back to before
the definition of differential privacy
using this like sub linear queries
framework of loved work McSherry and
Nassim which gave like sort of a
statistical queries implementation of
the perceptron algorithm and if you work
through the sample complexity you get
for this it's something like poly D over
alpha epsilon gamma another thing you
can do is cast this problem as a convex
empirical risk minimization problem
using the hinge loss and then this like
very nice line of work on doing gradient
descent and convex optimization shows
that you get a similar kind of bound so
a very nice recent work due to we John
and Lydia gave the first sort of
dimension independent balance for this
problem they showed that you can get
sample complexity which doesn't depend
on D so sort of morally similar to what
you can get from the perceptron
algorithm in non-private case and what
they do is they use this trick that
vitaly mentioned in his talk where you
first use dimensionality reduction in
particular at the johnson lyndon stress
lemma to project your d dimensional
domain into dimension roughly 1 over
gamma squared and then you can use like
techniques for private convex empirical
risk minimization to solve the problem
in the lower dimensional space so in
this work we use the boosting framework
which I'd mention which I talked about
before to give basically the same sample
complexity guarantees using like a
completely different method
okay so here's how the algorithm works
basically adopt or we basically adapts
for videos week learner in the most
obvious way so against four videos week
learner takes as input some weighted
sample computes this normalized centroid
of attention at the example and we saw
that's if you have a large margin half
space then this week learner is
guaranteed advantage at least the game
over to okay so do the most obvious
thing to get a CDP week learner which is
that instead of reporting this true
center of attention you add
appropriately scaled Gaussian noise to
it okay and then if you walk through the
calculation you can show that the
advantage of this week learner decreases
by Sigma over epsilon and you get
epsilon squared over 2 Sigma CD is
alright
so let's see what happens when we plug
this week learner into the boosting
framework so we have this CDP week
learner that has advantage game over 2a
minus Sigma over Epsilon
our goal is to learn a half space with
margin gamma to accuracy alpha with
privacy loss epsilon total so I mean
here's the algorithm from before let's
see what sample complexity we get out of
this so again we're going to take the
smoothest parameter Sigma to be 1 over
alpha n so if you plug this into the
guarantee for the week learner you'll
see that if you want to get advantage
which is proportional to gamma you
should take Sigma over epsilon to be
proportional to gamma now Sigma we said
was 1 over alpha and so working this out
you get that n has to be at least about
1 over alpha epsilon gamma all right so
using advanced composition for CDP the
total privacy loss of this algorithm as
a whole it's going to be something like
square root of the number of rounds
times Epsilon
plug epsilon total over root log 1 over
alpha or gamma in for epsilon here and
you get the final sample complexity
ballad of 1 over epsilon gamma squared
just some algebra
alright so there's some cool properties
of this learner for half-spaces using
first thing so the first nice property
is that it automatically tolerates
malicious noise so sir video showed that
smooth boosting tolerates malicious
noise and in addition his yeah weak
learner for half-spaces
is the same so plugging all this stuff
in shows that our algorithm also
tolerates the roughly the same level of
malicious noise another nice property is
that our algorithm is like very simple
and computationally efficient even for
getting a CDP guarantee at the end of
the day so this other work when Olman
and ii Fino showed actually two variants
of the result one which is inefficient
for pure differential privacy and one
which is efficient but only guarantees
approximate differential privacy or
truncated differential privacy another
nice feature is that basically the same
algorithm generalizes to this P norm
generalization of the so I just want to
spend a few minutes talking about
generalization which is kind of like the
last piece of the puzzle here so I
showed the first thing gives you an
algorithm that gets good empirical error
alpha but I mean of course we want these
to generalize to the underlying
distribution so again I want to you know
draw your attention to this part of safe
sir videos analysis of the boosted
learner for a large margin how spaces so
sort of the the general question for
generalization bounds is to identify
conditions on the learner H that will
guarantee that if H has low error say
alpha with respect to the sample s then
it has roughly the same error like alpha
over to say with respect to the
underlying population D so the first
like general tool for doing this is
using combinatorial properties of the
class functions from wit H comes from
particular can use the v c-dimension and
these results show that if your final
hypothesis H comes from some class Big H
then it's enough to take the number of
samples to be at least the v c-dimension
organization in the case of half-spaces
when the output hypothesis that you
produce is like itself a half space and
D dimensions with no other like
knowledge about where it comes from the
VC dimension of this is d which is
unfortunate so this work of sir video
got around this to give something better
based on margin based generalization so
if you know instead that your hypothesis
H can be written as the sine of some
real valued function where F comes from
functions f and moreover there should be
a little F
moreover the margin of this hypothesis
is good on all points in your input
sample then it suffices to take a number
of samples that's at least the fat
shattering dimension of this class of
real valued functions at scale depending
on your margin all right so I want to
find chattering dimension is but for D
dimensional half-spaces
just comes out to 1 over Zeta squared if
Zeta is your margin lower bound okay and
this makes poke very happy so sir video
showed that the H produced by adaboost
when run on this weak learner produces a
hypothesis with margin at least gamma
over 2 you put all this stuff together
and you get that it suffices to take and
to be at least 1 over alpha gamma
squares okay and then this margin
analysis works for our result as well so
this is enough samples to get our
hypothesis to generalize ok so I want to
point out potentially a third way of
proving generalization bounds which is
just to invoke the kind of
generalization you can get from
differential privacy itself so there's
this you know very nice line of work
showing that differentially private
algorithms run on iid samples
automatically generalize and this sort
of like a killer app for the stuff is
doing adaptive data analysis but it
works you know just in the arbitrary
settings where you want to use a
differential a private algorithm over at
these samples so sort of the the
punchline for this work is that if you
want to get this type of generalization
suffice is to have h come from a
differentially private algorithm where
epsilon is order alpha okay so for our
particular result about privately
learning large margin half spaces this
isn't terribly interesting because if
you set epsilon to be alpha you get that
the number of samples has to be at least
one over alpha squared gamma squared
which is not better than what you get
using a margin but if you if instead of
looking at the traditional PAC learning
case you look at the setting of noise
tolerant learning this gives you
something somewhat interesting so
remember that in the in the PAC setting
we're given samples that come IID from
some distribution D in the framework of
noise tolerant learning you're given a
different example Oracle which with
probability 1 - ADA gives you like a
clean example which is independent from
the underlying distribution and with
probability ADA you get some like
arbitrary adversarially chosen example
both in terms of the point and the label
so sir videos showed that his smooth
boosting algorithm
perhaps pace is able to tolerate
malicious noise in this model at a rate
of ada being about alpha times gamma and
using margin based arguments showed that
just generalizes as long as n is at
least 1 over alpha squared gamma squared
so our private booster also works in
this setting of noise color our learning
and so even if you don't care about
privacy if you set epsilon to be alpha
you get the same generalization bound
that's sir video got using margins
okay so I want to conclude with a few
further directions most of which I think
should be doable but I'm less confident
than the stuff that about this than the
stuff that I talked about already
so like another you know a good question
is whether you can get like genuinely
new sample complexity lower sample
complexity balance / no it's tolerant
learning yes for television you sort of
need the difference with private weak
learner in this setting right to get
generalization yes yeah so I'm talking
about using the differentially private
weak learner when you set epsilon to be
alpha then you will get a noise tolerant
learner that also happens to be
differentially private but generalizes
for this for the particular for the
particular algorithm I said
[Applause]
see it'd be good to get genuinely new
sample complexity Balfour annoyed
tolerant learning using this connection
to differential privacy it's also
probably likely that we can get a
private research for agnostic learning
which is in some sense a stronger or
more challenge in setting than noise
color learning another question is
whether boosting based algorithms can be
practical so sort of like until that
adaboost was like the first practical
boosting algorithm because of this like
adaptive thing where the multiplicative
weights updates can be made to the pen
sort of on how well previous hypotheses
were doing and so this like can
dramatically decrease running time
sample complexing us up so it'd be nice
to come up with a adaptive boosting all
the room for differential privacy and
finally it'd be great to come up with
sort of more general connections between
differential privacy and noise tolerant
learning and broader settings so for
instance in robust estimation which is
different than these like kind of
classification problems we've talked
about where you can where you want to
estimate like parameters of
distributions and stuff where some of
the samples that you're given have been
corrupted arbitrarily Thanks
[Applause]
animal bottom so basically the only
thing is you need to get the agnostic
boosting nearly is the optimal
smoothness BAM
I make sure you actually do it with
alpha and as a coolness party so do not
get the optimism as Constantine for your
booster I don't know you have to work
this out and we had we just haven't like
looked at doing it
yeah this is kind of a question for both
you and vitelli in some sense that it
seemed that you know the thing that a
Marcin gives you is that the sort of
optimal solution is really really
well-defined whole area of solutions
that are all really good and I wonder
but it's very specific to classification
and I'm just wondering if there are
other notions of kind of well well the
finest of the of the solution to a
problem that would also like those seem
like notions that lend themselves well
to generalization right but also to
privacy for the same reason that like in
some sense that the solution is kind of
over defined than one you know moving
around examples and gonna know you've
changed too much and I guess it's just a
like a kind of a an open-ended question
are there other notions of well-defined
in this of a solution that might make
sense in this kind of application and
also that might sort of make just as
good sense for non-free there
unsupervised settings or things that
we're you know
like binary levels this is to conserve
some working clustering on things like
I'm not sure it's time what you get is
that you get big bowl of solutions
doesn't necessarily mean that the
solution is well defined by the data in
at least and in this specific example of
for support because we know that there
is some canonical solution is evolved
and it is kind of robust so all of its
perturbation a solution but there might
be various practice out there which do
reveal a lot about the data so just just
about this intuition I'm not so sure if
that so there is a setting in which
things are better defined as let's say
if you have like strong convexity then
there things are equal we find that we
know they're closely related to by this
generalization and friends